(whoosh and click)
- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat deep bass guitar music)
- Hello, good afternoon.
I'm John Campbell, a philosophy
professor here at Berkeley,
and I'd like to welcome you
to this rainy windswept Howison Lecture.
George Howison was born in 1834.
He really entered academic
life as a mathematics professor
at the University of
Washington at St. Louis,
so he began his academic life
as a mathematics professor
but in St. Louis, he joined a group
who were reading Hegel's
Phenomenology of Spirit.
This was a rather
rambunctious, larger than life,
collection of academic characters.
The St. Louis Hegelians
were a very vibrant force.
They were very engaged with
and ultimately swept away
by the emerging naturalism
in American philosophy.
Howison's legacy was
perhaps the most enduring
of any of them.
He seems to have had Josiah Royce,
in particular, as his nemesis.
Howison wrote:
The most depressing sign
about Josiah Royce's thinking
is that he seems perfectly aware
how this makes no provision
either for immortality or for real freedom
and yet he appears to have
no uneasiness under it
but to contemplate this
ghastly destiny of ours
with a complacency even
savoring of self-satisfaction.
(audience laughing)
Howison had a lot of gusto I think.
He became the holder of
the first endowed chair
in philosophy at Berkeley,
and he built the philosophy department.
He was evidently an influential
and much-loved individual,
and on his death, his
friends and colleagues
put together a fund that
is funding today's lecture
to continue his work by bringing
the most influential figures
of the day to speak here.
And I think we really
couldn't have a better person
to fill that role than
Professor Kwame Anthony Appiah.
He's had many awards and honors.
A representative sample
would be, for example,
the National Humanities Medal,
Forbes magazine put him on a list
of the world's seven
most powerful thinkers.
This is not usually what happens
to philosophy professors.
(audience laughing)
In his many books, he's challenged
and engaged with questions
about identity and culture
that matter to all of us every day.
He said that we should live
with fractured identities,
engage in identity play,
find solidarity, yes,
but recognize contingency,
and above all practice irony.
In a memorable passage, he said,
"The truth is that there are no races.
"There is nothing in the world
we can ask race to do for us.
"As we've seen, even the biologists notion
"has only limited uses,
"and the notion that underlies
the more hateful racisms
"of the modern era refers to
nothing in the world at all."
But he's written across a
very wide range of subjects.
His dissertation was in
probabilistic semantics,
his first two books were
on philosophy of language.
He's written three novels.
It's been an extraordinary career
covering a panorama of topics,
and today we are privileged
to hear the latest direction
of his current work,
which as I understand it,
he's opening up the topic of idealization.
So his lecture today is called
the Philosophy of "As If."
Will you please join me in
welcoming Professor Appiah.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Thanks very much for
that kind introduction.
Imagine you were raised in a devout
Shui-Bian parsonage near
Tuebingen in the mid-19th century.
That may be hard for some of you.
And grew up with great respect
for the leading theologians of your age.
Imagine, too, that you had
the profoundest engagement
with the ethical and aesthetic
aspects of Christianity.
Suppose, finally, that you
became a serious student
of Kant and Schopenhauer Nietzsche
and that you moved in part as a result
from theism, to pantheism, to agnosticism,
while retaining your Christian ethical
and aesthetic commitments.
Then, since like all
educated men and women
of your place and time, you were familiar
with classical Greek and Roman ideas,
you might come to feel, quote,
according to the customs of
the cultured Greeks and Romans,
one may regard and treat
these myths as myths
and yet, or rather, just because of this
continue to esteem such fictions
for their ethical and aesthetic value.
This was pretty much what
happened to Hans Vaihinger,
the philosopher who wrote those words
in his autobiographical essay,
which preceded his 1911 magnum opus
(speaking in foreign language)
translated in 1924 into
English by CK Ogden
as The Philosophy "of As If".
Vaihinger tells us there,
that he breached the view
that theology was composed
of, what he called, myths
by his mid-20s, about the
time of his graduation
from the University of Tuebingen.
Over the next 40 years as a student
of the history of mathematics
and the physic physical sciences
and while keeping up with
the psychology of his day,
Vaihinger came to apply the same strategy
over and over again to
one field after another.
Abandoning realism about a domain, atoms,
infinitesimally, imaginary numbers, law,
space, abstract objects, force,
economics, freedom, the idea of freedom,
but maintaining what he called his esteem,
for the corresponding ideas
because of their utility.
And in explicitly connecting
this strategy with the one
that Kant had made famous in arguing
that rational agency required
us to act as if we were free,
even though our theoretical understanding
showed that we were
governed by immutable laws,
he claimed a Kantian
ancestry for his ideas.
Indeed in the final section
of the philosophy of as if,
Vaihinger records scores
of places in Kant's work
where his great predecessor
speaks of proceeding
as if what is theoretically
known to be false, is true.
Vaihinger's suggestion that
large areas of our thought
are fictions amounts to this.
Very often we can reasonably proceed,
as if what we know to be false, were true,
because it's useful for
some purpose to do so.
There were shades here
of pragmatism of course,
on the first page of the
general introductory remarks
on fictional constructs, Vaihinger wrote,
it must be remembered, that
the object of the world
of ideas as a whole, is not
the portrayal of reality,
this would be an utterly impossible task
but rather to provide an instrument
for finding our way about
more easily in the world.
Vaihinger proposed in essence
that an idealization is a useful fiction.
Or as he once put it that fictions are
errors but fruitful errors.
And for anyone interested in
this powerful way of thinking
about idealization, Vaihinger
work is a treasure trove
of interesting resources.
But there's one way
which Vaihinger differs
from at least one strand of pragmatism;
he thinks that there's a
gap between what is true
and what it is useful to believe.
That's why he asserts that
most of our thought is fiction.
If you equated the true
and the useful to believe
as people say some pragmatists do,
then you would lose exactly the contrast
that guided the philosophy of 'As If'.
And that book is the work
of a modern philosopher
who thought long and hard about
this particular tangle of ideas
and thought about its application
over the widest range.
Others may have gone
deeper into idealization
in one sphere or another, but Vaihinger,
is the first thinker I
know of who defined clearly
the issues I'd like to come to grips with.
Vaihinger's notion of what
he called a real fiction
is I think in one way quite surprising.
A real fiction he held,
involved a thought,
that was not just false but
in some way contradictory.
As he thought such useful ideas
as the square root of a negative number
or the atom were contradictory.
On his view, when we understand the world
as composed of atoms,
remember we are in the physics
and chemistry of the late 19th century,
we're supposing something
that we know to be impossible.
Suppose quote, following
(speaks foreign language),
a quartet of distinguished 19th
century physical scientists,
"Suppose we designate the atoms
"as centers without extension.
"The result," he said,
"turns out to be a very
strange construction indeed.
"For an entity without extension
that is at the same time
"a substantial bearer of forces,
"that is simply a combination of words
"with which no definite
meaning can be connected."
Defining an atom as a point mass
seems to require among
other things for example,
that it should be, infinitely dense.
What sense, Viahinger
makes one want to ask,
can one make of that?
Similarly, like many in
his day Viahinger thought
there was something simply contradictory
in the conception of the imaginary number,
which Gauss had made
such successful use of
in the early 19th century.
Viahinger's view is nicely articulated
in a famous conversation
in Robert Musil's novel,
Die Verwirrungen des Zöglings Törless.
There he describes a conversation
between Törless, the
protagonist and a friend
about imaginary numbers.
Törless objects that quote,
this is my translation,
you wouldn't like to hear
me read it in the German.
Törless objects that quote,
there is no such thing,
any number, whether it's
positive or negative
yield something positive
when it's squared,
so there can't be a bonafide number.
That's the square root
of something negative.
But Törless insists, what's
remarkable, is precisely,
one can really do calculations
with such imaginary
or otherwise impossible values
and end up with a tangible result.
Or as Viahinger puts it in one of his
characteristic paradoxes,
the concept in question is
contradictory but necessary.
Viahinger contrasted these real fictions
with what he called semi-fictions
where the concepts quote,
Only contradict reality is
given or deviate from it
but are not in themselves contradictory.
One clear example he gives would be
Adam Smith's rational egoism.
Which Viahinger understands
as an assumption
that Smith knew to be false.
But which nevertheless allowed
the Scottish philosopher
to construct a useful
predictive economics.
Quote, the empirical
manifestations of human actions
are so excessively complicated,
that they present almost
insuperable obstacles
when we try to understand
them theoretically
and reduce them to causal factors.
For the construction of his
system of political economy
this is still Viahinger, it
was essential for Adam Smith
to interpret human activity causally.
With unerring instinct he realized,
that the main cause lay in egoism
and he formulated his
assumption in such a way
that all human actions, and particularly
those of a business or
political economical nature,
could be looked upon as if
their driving force lay
in one factor, egoism.
Thus, all subsidiary causes
and partially-conditional
factors such as goodwill,
habit and so forth,
are here neglected.
With the aid of this
abstract cause, Adam Smith
succeeded in bringing the
whole of political economy
into an ordered system.
Nevertheless Viahinger
went on to argue, these,
quote, 'provisional assumptions'
are or at least should be,
accompanied by the consciousness
that they do not correspond to reality
and that they deliberate they substitute
a fraction of reality,
for the complete range
of causes and effects.
Now the difficulty with Viahinger's idea
of the contradictory fiction,
of the model that's literally
inconsistent is obvious.
It makes it very hard to understand
how an idealization can be useful,
since, as we teach our
students in introductory logic
if a theory is inconsistent
we can deduce from it
anything at all.
And the prediction that
something will happen
and that it won't happen,
can't surely be useful,
indeed it's not really a prediction.
Of course, one can construct
paraconsistent logics
in which the general thesis
that from a contradiction
anything follows, fails.
But I suspect that the way that many
of our actual inconsistencies
are actually corralled in,
is not by the implementation
of a non-standard logic,
but by what you might
call functional isolation,
so that in effect we have a
large set of families of beliefs
each of which we try to keep consistent
and these families aren't
usually brought together
in deliberation so the contradictions
are as it were kept apart.
David Lewis the philosopher
once exemplified
this sort of thing in a nice way,
in a story about how he
failed for a while to notice
that he acted as if a
certain Street in Princeton
was parallel to the railway
track for some purposes
and orthogonal to it for other purposes.
In Euclidean space that's not possible.
Now, everybody has experiences
of the inconsistency
of such internal maps.
Some of our colleagues working
in the philosophy of
science have suggested,
that scientific explanations
in contemporary physics
do involve mathematically
inconsistent theories
or to speak more carefully,
involve the application at the same time
of models that are
inconsistent with each other,
even of each of them is itself consistent.
Actually using these theories
involves in effect then,
knowing which lines of
inference one should
and which one should not follow.
Nancy Cartwright for example,
has criticized what she
calls the vending machine
model of theories, in which you
feed in certain I'm quoting,
certain prescribed forms
for the desire output,
it gurgitates for a
while, then it drops out
the sort for representation,
plunk on the tray
fully formed as Athena
from the brain of Zeus.
"I'd rather," she argues,
"the process involves
"knowing how to take advantage
"of the available formal resources,
"to treat a specific phenomenon."
If she's right, then Viahinger's idea
that idea our idealizations
are contradictory,
may turn out, in a way, to be correct.
But that's because the
understanding of the world
implicit in the scientific theory,
the knowledge it delivers, is held,
not just in the abstract
statement of the theory
but in the skill of applying it
to certain standard cases in particular,
sorry in certain standard cases,
in particular to what Cartwright
calls ontological machine,
not sorry, nomological machines,
where a nomological
machine is as she says,
"A fixed enough arrangement
of components or factors,
"with stable enough
capacities that in the right
"sort of stable enough environment
"will with repeated operation,
"give rise to the kind of regular behavior
"that we represent in our scientific laws.
"A nomological machine,"
she gives the solar system as one example,
"is screened off enough
from outside forces
"that we can make roughly
reliable laws about its motions."
So the physicists knowledge is not held
in the formal theory,
which is one reason why
it's inconsistency should worry us less.
I don't know enough about
the relevant physics
to evaluate many of these claims,
but they surely do support the idea
that Viahinger was right
about something important.
You can't refute the idea
that our best theories are inconsistent,
by arguing that the world
itself can't be inconsistent
unless you presuppose
that our best theories,
aim only at truth.
There's a point here of some importance,
even if it may prove controversial.
Once we grant that our
models assume what is not so,
the fact that another
representation is inconsistent
with the model we currently accept,
cannot by itself count,
against accepting it too.
For we know, ex hypothesi,
that we already have a picture
that is untrue to how
things strictly speaking are
and the success of our current model
for some purpose or other,
cannot count against
accepting another model
that is inconsistent with
it, for at least two reasons.
One, is that just because our theory,
which is not strictly true,
succeeds to some degree for some purpose.
We cannot infer that another
theory inconsistent with it
could not also succeed, to
more or less the same degree
for the same purpose?
And the other is that, what is
successful for some purposes,
may not be successful for others.
The result is that Viahinger
can give us an explanation
for why we might profit from
mobilizing a set of theories
that are inconsistent with one another.
Another of Vaihinger distinctions
between what he called fictions
and what he called hypotheses is,
surely uncontroversially helpful.
Viahinger's point was
at the very same claim,
Adam Smith's claim say that
men are rational egoists,
could be treated either as a
fiction, a fruitful untruth
or as something whose actual truth
remains an open possibility.
And a good deal of Viahinger's
argument demands to saying,
that many theories that
are offered as hypotheses,
need not be given up
because some of their claims
are known to be false, because
we can continue with them,
treating them now as fictions.
But if idealization is Viahinger proposed
the question of useful untruths,
there are now two questions
to ask that are familiar
from the discussions of pragmatist ideas
about what it is useful to believe.
First, useful for what?
And second, if a falsehood is useful,
isn't there some truth in the vicinity
that would be even more useful?
Why stick with the useful and truth?
Won't the truth always be better?
And I'll return to that second line
of questioning in a
moment, but for the moment
let's stick with the
first, useful for what?
One old line of thought
here, it's a thought
almost as old as systematic
philosophy in the West,
is that utility means usefulness
in saving the phenomena.
Simplifying idealization is useful,
if it allows us to cover the past record
and predict the future
course of our experiences.
But despite some passages
that suggest this picture,
I don't think this is Viahinger's view.
What he thought, as I've
essentially already pointed out,
was that it was in controlling the world
that thought proved itself useful,
our representations prove
themselves useful, and even though
sensation is our only means
of access to the world,
thoughts object is not to
manufacture or predict sensations
but to control the world
that produces them.
Viahinger's treatment
has the great virtue,
that it responds in
regards questions about
our everyday thinking about the world,
that's continuous with
our scientific thinking.
"Both aim," he says,
"at controlling reality,
"both leave things out, in
order to make it practicable
"to represent the world
we're trying to control."
So Viahinger believes our representations
are fundamentally tools that
allow us to control the world,
but why must they be idealized?
Let's begin by extamining a
passage Viahinger refers to
in once more, a 19th century discussion
of Adam Smith's idealizations
which we've already
been talking about.
He's quoting here Henry
Thomas Buckle's introduction
to The History of Civilization in England.
"Adam Smith in his Wealth of Nations,
"simplified the study of human nature
"by curtailing it of all its sympathy.
"But," he continued, "this
most comprehensive thinker
"was careful in his Theory
Of the Moral Sentiments
"to restore the human nature,
"the quality of which
the wealth of patience
"had deprived it.
"And thus by establishing two
different lines of argument,
"he embraced the whole subject."
Now, Buckle is overreaching
here for the complete treatment
would presumably include
not just egoism and sympathy
but all the psychological factors relevant
for explaining human behavior.
And as is clear from the
passage I cited earlier,
one of Vaihinger's insights is that
it's precisely the difficulty
of embracing the whole subject
that makes idealization
inescapable on his view.
It's the fact that the phenomena
are an excessively complicated
that requires us to leave
out some of the details.
But to say that the
complexity is excessive,
is to make a point not
so much about the world
as about our capacity to understand it.
The complexities exceed
our cognitive capacity
to encompass them and this
is a fact as much about us
as about them.
Suppose for example
that the quantum theory
were precisely true,
in (scoffs) sorry.
That may stretch your
imaginative capacities,
it certainly stretches mine.
In principle, I suppose
that would allow us to write
a precise equation for each
of the atoms in a baseball.
To describe the baseball we would then
have to solve a system of
the order of something like
10 to the 26 equations.
No human being, I suggest,
knows how to do this,
no machine exists that could do it either
and even if there were such a machine,
what an earth use would it be to us?
If the utility of scientific fiction
derives from the excessive
complexity of the world
that is from the fact that
its complexity exceeds
our cognitive capacities,
the utility of religious
myth for Viahinger
seems to come from somewhere else.
He pronounces himself here a
disciple of Friedrich Langer
who had articulated a
standpoint of the ideal
that permits a metaphysical atheist,
nevertheless to hold
on to religion as myth
because of what he calls the
ethical efficacy of religious language.
Viahanger did not think atheists
couldn't have moral ideas,
he did not think that if God was dead
everything was permitted
but he did think that we
more likely to be able
to live by our ideals, if we express them
poetically as it were,
in religious language.
This is meant so far as I can see,
is an empirical claim.
And I'm not going to canvas the evidence
for or against it here.
Richard Braithwaite, one
of my earliest teachers
in philosophy, argued later,
that one could understand
and adopt religious belief
without an appeal to theology,
in effect, he thought, one could treat
the Creed he recited on Sundays,
explicitly as fiction.
And Viahinger's treatment,
certainty of argument
shows that the utility of
fictions can be conceived
not only in their power to aid us
in manipulating the world outside us,
but also in their capacity
to help us manage ourselves.
His thought like Kant's thought about
the inevitability of the idea of freedom
in the world of the understanding,
is that we can grasp theoretically,
that the ideas we're using a false,
while still finding
them practically useful
indeed, inescapable.
So I suppose with Viahinger
that useful means,
useful for managing the world
including sometimes ourselves.
Then there's a puzzle about how
we can make good predictions
by leaving stuff out.
Vaihinger's answer I think,
first answer I think,
can be twofold; first,
sometimes leaving stuff out
makes too little difference to matter
for the purpose at hand,
as when we use the Newtonian
rather than Einstein
in mechanics in building a bridge.
This is a very familiar thought
and the example is a familiar example.
But Vaihinger also thought,
the question had a second
more interesting answer,
sometimes our idealizations
allow us to get things right
because we proceed as
it were in two steps.
First, ignoring a range of phenomena
in order to build a model
of a world without them
and then once we've grasped
how that model works,
adding more and more of
the world gradually back in
as he puts it, "If in fictions
thought contradicts reality,
"or if it even contradicts itself
"and in spite of this
questionable procedure,
"it nevertheless succeeds in
corresponding to reality then,"
and this is a necessary inference,
"this deviation must have been corrected
"and the contradiction
must have been made good."
Viahinger was in the end,
something of an instrumentalist
about theory.
He focused as we've seen
on the role of our theories
in controlling the world.
But this line of thinking adamanted here,
might suggest another view,
in which we take the role
of the idealized model
as helping us not just
or not even to predict
or control the world,
but to understand it.
That is a really important idea I think,
I have only time here however
to note it and march on.
And you know, when I finish
the book on this topic
I will say more about that question
but I'm going to mark it here
is an important possibility.
'Cause I wanted now to discuss a second,
more recent philosopher,
first because his work can
be taken as a case study
of Viahinger's philosophy of the 'as if',
and second because in the course
of thinking about his proposals,
we can come to see the
power of Viahinger's picture
in framing our understanding
of idealization.
The philosopher I have in
mind is Daniel Dennett,
who has urged us to adopt what he calls,
"the intentional stance" to many things,
ourselves among them and to
adopt "the design stance"
to many things too,
ourselves included as well.
To adopt the intentional
stance towards something,
is to treat it or her as if
she were a rational agent
with beliefs and desires,
the beliefs and desires it ought to have
given its place in the
world and its purpose,
and then to predict what
this rational agent will do
in order to further its goals.
Similarly, to adopt the design
stance towards organisms
and the things they produce,
is to treat them as if they were designed
to perform certain functions
and this can allow us to
predict what they will do,
just as we explain what it is
to be an intentional system
by specifying the intentional stance,
so we can say what it is
to have a certain function
by adopting the design stance,
by treating something
as if it had been made
by a designer with certain aims.
In each case, adopting
a stance of this sort
involves treating something
as if something were so,
as if it had internal
states of belief and desire,
as if it were the product
of intentional design.
So Dennett too as I say, is
a philosopher of the 'as if'.
I've been arguing with Viahinger,
that we do this a whole
lot in many domains,
Dennett agrees.
But that this is what we
are doing leads laterally
back to the question why it works.
If it works, I've suggested we have reason
to go along with it, even perhaps
at the price of inconsistency.
That is what Nancy Cartwright taught me
about much physics.
It's what Viahinger
thought about theology,
number theory, physics and economics,
it's what Braithwaite thought
about religious language.
But showing that it does
work, doesn't explain why.
Cartwright believes, that it works
because our theories latch
on to what she calls,
the real capacities of much of the world.
As far as I know she's right.
But I want now to explore the question,
why idealization works,
by thinking through
some of Daniel Dennett's
insistence on the importance
of the as if in the case of the mind.
Dennett claims at least sometimes,
that beliefs, but I've
already given you reason
for not worrying too
much about inconsistency,
so I won't point out
that another occasions
he says the opposite.
Dennett claims, that beliefs and desires
are real states of
people, the states in fact
which make it possible for us
to predict what they will do
by adopting the intentional strategy.
Quote, to a first approximation
the intentional strategy
consists of treating the object
whose behavior you want to predict,
as a rational agent
with beliefs and desires
and other mental states exhibiting what
Brentano and others call intentionality.
To do this you must figure
out what beliefs and desires
the agent ought to have
given its place in the
world and its purposes.
Then you figure out what
desires it ought to have
on the same considerations,
and finally you predict
what that rational agent
will act to further
its goals in the light of
its beliefs and desires.
The agent therefore must
be reasonable in two ways,
it must first form its beliefs and desires
in ways that are reasonable
and second it must perform
the acts that are reasonable
given those beliefs and desires.
This is what it is to adopt
the intentional stance
towards it.
What it is finally to
have beliefs and desires,
is to be and I quote,
an intentional system,
a system whose behavior is reliably
and voluminously predictable
via the intentional strategy.
Now here's a question,
does it matter why the agent's behavior
is predictable in this way?
If I have beliefs and
desires and I'm rational,
the reason the intentional strategy
of treating me as a
rational agent works is,
well, that I am a rational
agent with beliefs and desires.
It works because it
treats me as what I am.
If the intentional strategy
works with something
that doesn't have both beliefs and desires
and behave rationally on the one hand,
the success of those reliable
and voluminous predictions
might seem to be just a mystery.
But then it serves up an
example that's supposed to show
why the success of the intentional stance
can in fact, be quite unmysterious.
Consider, he suggests,
a computer chess program
and ask yourself how to
predict what it will do.
Reading the program or worse,
looking at the transistors of the computer
that is implementing, it
isn't going to be much help.
It would take you too long
to read and understand the program,
at least if it's any good.
A much better way to predict
what moves it will make,
is to ask yourself this question,
what would a reasonable person
who knows the rules and
the aim of chess do,
faced with this board?
You'd figure the computer
knows how to play chess,
wants to win and will act accordingly.
You would in short, adopt
the intentional stance.
You would do pretty much
exactly what you would do
if you were trying to predict the moves
that a person would make.
The reason this will
usually work of course,
is that this is what the
computer was designed to do.
It is meant to make the
best move that it can.
The better the design,
the more likely it is
that the intentional strategy will work
though and again of course,
if it's really well designed,
it will see more possibilities
and opportunities
than most of us mortals and so we will get
our predictions wrong.
We may understand looking
backwards why it did what it did
but we won't be able to predict it,
'cause it's better at chess than we are.
Predicting the moves of deep-blue,
the program that beat Garry
Kasparov in 1997, is something
only possible for the
grandest of grand masters.
The Scarecrow it's
around knows, knows how,
wants and sees in some
of Dennett's writings
about this topic draw,
attention to the fact,
that most of us, in adopting
the intentional stance
towards a computer, and let's admit it,
we all do that often,
we nevertheless take talks
of beliefs and desires
to be figurative, not literal.
A facon de parler where we are clear
that our mode is a kind of fiction.
With humans on the other
hand, we take it literally
and also with many other animals.
I think the sheep on our farm
know that we'll feed them.
They don't just know it
and you probably have analogous
thoughts about your dog.
Dennett tells us that we
should simply postpone
the question of whether
it really has a mind.
Unfortunately, there are reasons to worry
about whether any actual thing
really has a mind on
Dennett's view, here's why.
You and I are supposed to
be intentional systems.
We can be reliably
predicted by approaching us
with the intentional stance.
So we meet one of Dennett's criteria.
But neither you nor I is fully rational.
Indeed, that we are going
to do irrational things
is equally voluminously predictable.
So it remains a bit of a mystery
why the intentional
strategy succeeds with us
on the occasions where it does.
Dennett does not I think,
stress sufficiently the fact,
that the strategy also fails a great deal.
This is in part because the
sort of rationality in question
is extremely demanding.
It involves having all the
beliefs and desires we ought
to have and acting only as
we ought to act given them.
And the evident fact that
many people don't believe
what they ought to, that the
president was born in Hawaii,
for example or desire what they should,
to abstain from smoking for example,
is one reason why the strategy
is not guaranteed to succeed.
So, if you have to be fully rational
to have beliefs and desires,
then so it seems to me I
don't have beliefs and desires
and not to put too fine a
point upon it, nor do you.
Dennett has an answer to the question
why the intentional strategy
works as often as it does.
He thinks we were designed
by evolution to work this way
and so as you see, unlike
many realist philosophers,
he thinks there is nothing
wrong in speaking of organisms
or their parts as designed
by evolution to do things.
This makes sense to him
because as I said he thinks
that just as we can adopt
the intentional strategy
towards people and animals and computers,
we can adopt the design stance
towards organisms and
the things they produce.
We can treat them as if they were designed
to perform certain functions
and this can allow us to predict again,
reliably and voluminously,
what they will do.
Once you know what an alarm
clock or a chainsaw is for,
you know what it can do.
So too, for a kidney or a heart.
Here again, Dennett doesn't
think it helpful to distinguish
between what was really designed
by a capital D designer as it were
and what is merely predictable,
once we adopt the design stance.
In the history philosophy many things
have been called pragmatism,
but one central candidate
for the name is the thought
that our theories are to be evaluated
by what they enable us to do.
So you might think that
Dennett is here operating
in this good American
philosophical tradition.
If the intentional stance enables us
to predict the behavior of a computer,
why not just accept that it has beliefs
and desires and reasons?
But that is not what he actually says.
What he proposes instead
is that in the cases
where the intentional stance
is a rewarding strategy,
yielding a budget of useful predictions,
allowing us to manipulate
the world to our advantage,
shades there of Viahinger,
we should say, not that
the thing has beliefs,
but that it sorta has beliefs.
Dennett's use of the cosy word sorta,
he pokes fun at the style
of analytic philosophy
by insisting on calling
it the sorta operator,
is one of the more interesting things
in his recent philosophical writings.
Dennett uses this operator
in two crucial ways;
first, to talk about anything
to which we can productively
apply the intentional stance.
If the strategy works,
then the thing sorta
believes or desires.
Second, in the context of evolution
to talk about the relationship,
between species and their ancestors.
Before there were bacteria, he writes,
there were sorta bacteria,
and before there were mammals
there were sorta mammals,
and before there were dogs,
there were sorta dogs and so on.
It is easy to see one way in which
these two uses are connected.
For among the things that sorta believed,
were some of our sorta ancestors.
(scoffs) Beliefs came into being gradually
through an evolutionary process
and there's no exact moment when suddenly,
hey presto, full-fledged belief appeared,
just as there's no exact moment
when the first mammal was born.
There is no principle line Dennett writes,
above which true
comprehension is to be found.
Now as I say, like many of his ideas
I think this one is extremely interesting.
But is also I think, and also typically,
a little mysterious.
And the mystery just is the mystery
of why idealization is
a good strategy here,
why it so often works.
So I want to try and unpack
this mystery a little further.
In particular, let's no
longer postpone the question
whether anything has any actual beliefs.
Adopting the intentional stance
involves applying a
rather elaborate theory
to predict something's behavior.
You treat the putative agent
as having beliefs and desires
ascribed to it by supposing
it believes and desires
what is reasonable for it
to believe and to desire.
And then you predict that it will do
what it would be reasonable to do
granted that it has those internal states.
A creature that always had
the rationally required states
and did the rationally required thing,
let's call it a cognitive angel,
would always respond as the
intentional stance requires.
Its states would be full
fledged beliefs and desires,
no sorta about it.
But there are no cognitive angels.
So in the actual world,
every belief is a belief,
a sorta belief, and every
desire is a sorta desire.
No doubt some creatures
in our actual world
are closer to cognitive angels than others
in the sense that they will more often do,
in the circumstances of the actual world,
what a cognitive angel would have done.
You and I are no doubt
closer to a cognitive angel
than your dog, well at least you are.
Your dog is presumably closer than an ant.
An ant does a better
cognitive job than an amoeba,
maybe an amoeba does such a terrible job
that the intentional strategy with it
is a complete waste of time.
In some, the strategy of prediction,
the strategy we use to make sense
of the behavior of all the things
we can usefully treat
as intentional systems,
is to apply an idealized model,
knowing that just because it is idealized
it won't always get things right.
To say that something
sort of believes is to say
that the idealized model works for it
well enough to be getting along with.
If it worked perfectly, it
would be just plain true
that we believe, if it works
badly enough it's plain false,
in between is the vaguely delineated world
of the sorta true.
I doubt that Dennett
would accept this picture
of his proposal, as Robert's
Rules of Order rightly insist,
there is no such thing
as a friendly amendment.
Still, looking it this
way, helps us to see,
that the right answer to the question
whether anything at all
has a mind might be, sorta.
But being sorta true is not
a lesser way of being true,
it is a special way of being false.
And though it's easy
to see why a true story
might make the right predictions,
again, why should a false one?
And so we're brought back to the question
whether the fact that we
approximate a rational creature
isn't something of a mystery.
Dennett thinks it isn't because
he thinks we can understand
through evolutionary theory,
how they came to be creatures like us.
And at the heart of this understanding
is a claim he first made a long time ago,
at least as far back as Elbow Room,
his book on freedom of the will.
The world he thinks, is full of quote,
free-floating rationales,
reasons why creatures do what they do,
even though they don't know
that that is why they do them.
Squirrels burry nuts,
which they will be able
to eat in the winter.
They don't know this when they bury them
but still, that's the
reason why they do it.
They have purposes as he says,
but they don't need to know them,
the need to know principal
rains in the biosphere
and naturally sexual action itself,
doesn't need to know what it's doing.
Dennett thinks that the
evolution has endowed us
on the other hand, with the
capacity not just to have
but also to know our purposes.
And a proper evolutionary account
of how we came to be sorta agents,
with sorta beliefs and sort of
desires and sorta intentions
will make it less mysterious he thinks,
that we respond to reasons demands.
But notice that the explanation here
of why the intentional strategy
works for us in essence is,
that the design stance shows us
why we have come to be
intentional systems.
And what does that mean?
Well, that it is as if we were designed
to have intentional states.
But the mystery of why we can be managed
by an intentional systems approach,
is not explained by
saying that it is as if
we were designed to work intentionally,
it would only be explained if we were
designed to work intentionally.
We have just replaced
one mystery with another.
It is impasses such as
these that lead people
to want to say that
the fact that we can be
predicted and controlled in these ways,
shows that there is an underlying truth
that the theory captures.
That's why Dennett in some mood says
we do have beliefs and desires.
Ian Hacking has suggested
that what gives us reason
to be a realist about
things like positrons
is that we can manipulate
them, intervening in the world
on the basis of our beliefs about them.
Once he tells us when he was discussing
a physics experiment with a friend,
he asked how you altered the
charge on a niobium ball.
"Well, at that stage," said my friend,
"we spray it with positrons
to increase the charge
"or with electrons to
decrease the charge."
Hacking's response, "From that day forth
"I've been a scientific realist,
"so far as I'm concerned
if you can spray them,
"they're real." (audience laughs lightly)
And notice that like Viahinger,
his thought is not about
saving the phenomena
but about managing the world,
he's on Viahinger's side here.
Nancy Cartwright, it seems
odd to mention them both
regularly without mentioning
that they were once married
to one another but I won't.
Nancy Cartwright as I just pointed out,
thinks that the success of
the strategies of physics
gives us reason to
believe in the capacities
our physical laws, atom
break in precisely.
She has a book called how
the laws of physics lie.
What better reason we might
ask by parity of reasoning,
could there be than the successes
of the intentional strategy,
for believing in the intentional states?
Well, here's a better reason,
we'd have a better reason if the theory
didn't get so much wrong.
In particular, if it
didn't treat us as rational
in ways we already know we're not
and predict that we will
do things that we don't do.
On each trip of explanation every,
I'm sorry on each trip,
every train of explanation
comes to its last stop.
Unless you think the whole world
is the working out of
conceptual necessities,
you will have to accept that there are
some brute empirical truths.
And for the moment I am inclined to think
that the fact that the
intentional strategy works
to the extent that it does,
is in that way, brute.
Evolution apparently equipped us
with the intentional strategy,
and it was built-in but,
it was sorry, it was built into us,
I seem to have lost a page here,
presumably because it was adaptive.
But it seems to me that
it's not at all clear yet
why it is adaptive.
What features of it led to its selection.
And the hypothesis that
we really have states
that are like beliefs and desires,
is only one candid explanation.
Now a par with the churchlands,
you can't really doubt that you yourself
have beliefs and desires.
It's hard realistically to doubt
that other people have them,
except in the skeptical
or paranoid frame of mind
that can have you doubting
that anything at all
is really as it seems.
But it could be true,
even if you were wrong,
(speaks foreign language),
what cannot be doubted,
need not be true.
That idealization sorta works then,
is in many cases just
something that turns out
to be simply true.
There is in any case a reason to doubt
whether the question I
am asking is a fair one.
You cannot ask seriously why
our idealizations work for us
except from the point of view
of a picture of the world
that includes both us
and our idealizations.
A picture that is in that sense...
sorry, better than the one that
we actually currently have.
So that it seems to me that there's just
a reasonable thing we can say,
which is that we cannot do anything
from the point of view of
a theory we don't have.
If the question is how
to understand the fact
that our idealizations work,
we have to understand that question
against the background of a picture.
And the picture has to be one
which includes both us
in our idealizations
and if it's going to be very interesting
it had better be a better theory
than the one we've currently got.
But we can't do anything
from the point of a theory
that we haven't got.
And if that's right,
this sort of idealization
will only be possible as it
were in the rear view mirror.
And that should lead us to
revisit Viahinger's explanation
as to why idealization is necessary.
The question whether the
complexity for us of the world
explains our need for idealization,
requires us to have a picture,
of our own relation to the world.
If the only picture we have of the world
and of ourselves is an idealized one,
we have no strictly
and totally true theory
with which to approach this question.
We can try to answer it with
these useful false theories
but they will ex hypothesi,
represent the world
as simpler than it is.
So once more, it will only
be from the point of view
of theories that are better than ours,
that our question can be asked.
So we can look back to Newtonian physics
and ask why it worked well enough
in the circumstances of our world,
even though it ignored complexities
of which it was unaware.
And we can see from where we stand now,
that it would have been very difficult
with the tools both
experimental and theoretical
that the Newtonians mobilized,
to represent these
post-newtonian complexities.
I'm inclined to think that the question
I have been trying to
get Dennett to answer,
only makes sense as a
question we will ask later,
looking backwards at our present selves.
And only then, because we will suprose
that our later theories are better.
If that is right, then here as elsewhere
in Hegel's justly famous phrase,
the owl of Minerva flies at dusk.
Thank you.
(applause)
- [Man] I guess I'd like to ask about
the idea that common
sense psychology involves
this idealization of rationality.
I guess what I wonder is,
isn't it just a mistake
Dennett makes to say that we actually use
an idealization of rationality?
Suppose I own a casino and
I'm tryna set up the casino,
I wanna make a lot of money from this,
then idealizing that my patrons
have complete rationality
is (chuckles) going to make
life very difficult for me.
What I need, actually is
a very good understanding
of all the ways in which
they're irrational.
I mean I could be exhibiting
my grasp of folk psychology,
I could be the apotheosis of
a skilled folks psychologist
working with my clients irrationalities,
I don't need an idealization
of rationality here.
So it may be true that sometimes we assume
that people will get
the easy things right,
but if you're good at
interpersonal relations,
that may involve you often assuming
that they're gonna get stuff wrong.
- Good.
I mean I agree with what you just said.
I think that our capacity
to understand other people,
to predict them, to respond to them,
depends upon our knowing some truths
about the ways in which
we characteristically
deviate from all sorts
of forms of rationality.
This is a truth that even economists
have finally discovered (man chuckles).
I think that that shows that Dennett
sort of put it in the wrong way,
I don't think it shows
that he's clearly wrong.
And this relates to the question
that I put aside for the book
about the role of these idealized models
in understanding things as
opposed to in prediction.
We would like an account,
well philosophers anyway,
would like an account of what beliefs are.
And it seems to me very
hard to give an account
of what beliefs are in a way that ignores
certain norms about how beliefs
are supposed to operate.
So we do have, in our conception
of what the states are
that we're ascribing to people,
we have in not just in
philosophy but in ordinary life,
notions about what as you
said in the obvious case,
it would be reasonable
for a person to believe,
what it would be
reasonable for them to do,
given what we think they
believe in desire and so on.
Now, we also have again in common sense,
a bunch of ideas about
things that are obstacles
to carrying out the required thing.
We know that there are systemic ways
in which people make
failures of reasoning,
we know that for example,
forming beliefs about yourself
is especially difficult because
we're designed to have an interest
in representing ourselves
as better than we are.
There are lots of things we
know informally about that.
But it's still the case
that those are explanations
that attend to beliefs as things which
in the absence of those things,
would behave in the way
that reason requires.
When you're building your casino,
when you're managing your casino,
you have to treat people
both as for many purposes,
as doing what their beliefs
and desires require them to do.
They want to play the game,
they'll be willing to give you money,
in exchange for chips and so on.
All these things involve
treating them as having
desires and beliefs that are
working in the correct way
but then as you say, you will require,
if your casino is going to make any money,
you will require them to make bets
that they ought not to make.
And you know some things
as a casino operator
about what will make them do that.
For example, we know
that however irrational,
however clearly and false it is,
people think that they can
be on a winning streak.
So we should be attentive to
people who've won a few things
and encourage them to bet more,
that's one of the things we know.
Even though a properly scientifically
and rationally-trained
person will know that
that's the very moment
which you should realize
that you're subject to a very
characteristic human delusion.
But in that case, again,
we're understanding the state
that the thing they're
doing that's a deviation
from what's reasonable, in
terms of what it would be like
for them to do the reasonable thing
and we have an explanation
for the deviation.
So I think it's actually not in...
I really think that it's not
actually in predicting people,
which is anyway something
we don't do a lot of that
if you think about it,
I mean not individuals.
We do, but in general we rely on people,
well that's different
from predicting them.
But one reason why I knew that
you would come and
fetch me from the hotel,
wasn't a prediction,
it wasn't any elaborate
theoretical prediction,
you'd said you would
and I trusted you, right?
And you did.
And that's a normal
thing in human affairs.
I didn't need to know anything very much
about the rest of your internal states,
to rely on you in that way,
no, nothing elaborate.
If you hadn't come, I would
have entertained hypotheses
and they would have been hypotheses
that assumed you had some of
the normal desires and beliefs.
I would assume that you might
had a problem in your family,
I mean there are lots of things
that I would have guessed
might have happened.
And all of those again, those guesses
would be guided by the thought,
well, what should a person,
with these beliefs and desires do?
So we'd be back with the
sort of rational thing.
This is to do with how we
understand one another,
not how we predict one
another and I don't,
in general, here's something I know
because the general theory as
Dennett rightly insists is holistic,
I couldn't possibly know all the things
that could be relevant to
what you're going to do.
'cause anything, any proposition at all,
could come to be relevant
to what you're going to do.
If you came to believe
about that proposition,
that if it were true
you would gain something
by doing certain action.
And given the ways in which
people can come to have beliefs,
which include not just looking at things
but being told things,
pretty much anything can
come to occupy that position.
I can end up caring about
where the nearest star is
because there's a bet available, right?
If I get the right answer, I get $100.
So because of the elaborate holism,
the elaborate and rational holism, right?
If this bet is available,
it's reasonable for you
to take it if you think
you know the answer, right?
But I don't know which
of these things you know,
I don't know actually in very great detail
a lot about my own beliefs and desires.
And I have some access to them,
certainly don't know about
even the people I love
and know most dearly.
So I think focusing on the
sort of prediction side
I think focusing on
understanding and the way...
Again, this is a bit
of a different kind of,
owl of Minerva point,
that it's sort of looking
backwards at action very often
that rationality and
irrationality come into play.
But as I say, I think
in order to understand
the cases which are not rational,
we start by thinking of the states
that we're invoking as
if we understand them
through what it would
be for them to operate
rationally correctly,
I think that's right.
But it's different from what Dennett says.
- [Man In Stripped Shirt]
Thanks for the talk.
I wanted to ask you about
the thing you didn't wanna talk
about yet, so understanding.
- Yes.
- [Man In Stripped
Shirt] That seemed to me
to like be in between the
two things you discussed
that were seeking in
trying to explain things,
on the one end you're
trying to discover truths
and so this case where we have
an idealization where we
only act as if it's true,
really fails in that regard.
And then we might have this other thing
which is like pragmatic or useful,
we can use it to manipulate
the world or something
but it seemed to me that
understanding was a kind of
like epistemic middle ground
between those two things.
It's not just a brute fact
that acting in this way
allows us to like get something
in a kind of vulgar way
and it's not that it's true necessarily,
but we gain some other important
epistemic good namely like
coming to understand the world
we live in in a better way
and that's a really important part
of the scientific enterprise.
And so, yeah, that would seem
like the natural way to go
in trying to understand
why we do this thing
where we pretend as if something's true
when we really know that it's not.
And so I just want to hear what
you have to say about that.
- I agree with what you said.
I think to make sense of it
one has to tell a big story
about something, about
understanding something
and I don't have the memory (giggles).
I've got it written down
somewhere for one case.
But basically I think there is thiS,
so let me just say something about it
but won't probably seem very satisfactory.
I think at the heart of
this is something that,
we were saying this to
each other at lunch,
it's something that's
a very important part
of our natural history.
Which is our capacity for make-believe.
You do not have to teach
children make-believe.
This is the point that Kendall Walton
has made very eloquently.
Children spontaneously
treat lumps of mud as cakes,
your cellphone as a motor car and so on.
They spontaneously know it, we don't teach
pretending to children,
children know to pretend,
they come knowing how to prepare basically
and they do it all the time.
Walton has argued that this
is at the heart of fiction,
that what happens to
children's make-believe
is that it grows up and
becomes the novel and movies
and so on I think that's a plausible view,
though people in literary
studies don't always like it.
That is a very hard thing to understand,
what we're doing there.
I want to make the point both
that we all know how to do it,
we all did it without anyone
telling us how to do it,
we understand it
perfectly well in one way.
But actually it's really weird
what's going on there when
the child goes you know...
(imitates moving car)
Because for example, if
you put your hand up,
the child has to decide
whether the treat that
as an accident, or you
interfering with the game.
And it does one or other of those things
and it knows that they're different.
So we know from children,
how to treat a collection,
and ensemble of objects as if
they were some other things
and we know what the
boundaries are of that,
we know that it isn't
really a cake, the mud pie,
we know that certain moves with the mud,
count as serving the cake
and others count as changing the subject,
doing something else, stopping the game.
And that's essentially in grown-up form,
I think a lot of theorizing is like that
only perhaps we're less clear,
when we're doing theorizing
that that's what we're doing.
I mean what are children
doing in this case?
They're learning how the world works,
they're learning to understand the world.
They are actually picking up
on genuine features of the
world as they play these games.
And we are picking up on that's the point
about capacities in the Cartwright account
of why theories that aren't
strictly speaking inconsistent
and therefore couldn't be true,
can nevertheless help
us understand things.
But it's a bit mysterious
how that works I think.
You can say, perhaps we should say,
look what's going on here is
made possible by our access
to possibilities, to the
fact that we can understand.
So that what's going on is that
we have this amazing
capacity to understand
what it would be for the world
to be a certain way that it isn't
and we understand the
way that the world is,
in terms of pictures of
ways it might have been,
though it isn't.
I think that's true, I don't know
how deeply explanatory it is to say that,
but it is to say I think
that sort of possibilities
and maybe you don't like possible worlds,
but possibilities are key to this.
That understanding things
involves understanding
their possibilities, their capacities,
what they would do.
So take the simplest
case of an idealization,
the kind of Galilean story about
the ball moving down the inclined plane,
we tell a story in which we understand,
we imagine a world in
which there's no friction.
There is no such world, no actual world.
There is no place in the world with that,
well actually there is
now, with superconductors,
but anyway, forget about.
There are no actual inclined planes
with balls on them with no friction.
We get the story as it were exactly right
for a world with no friction.
Only that isn't this world,
it's this other world that
we know how to imagine.
And I think that capacity which we display
from the very beginning as
children in our make-believe,
is the one that is key to
sort of unpacking all this.
- [Man In Stripped Shirt] Thanks.
- [Man] So it sounds like
you're saying essentially that
philosophical systems are like toys,
like they're partial without our
pretending that they are
something or another.
And in Internet and youth culture
there's another operator, the kinda.
(Kwame laughs)
So the kinda and the sorta,
are you suggesting that
they are more accurate
or more valid or more precise in a way
than the definitive clauses?
- Well one thing I suppose
I would be inclined to say
is that there are very few
things that I know are true
but there are lots of things
that I know are sorta true.
So very often if I say
something's sorta the case,
I'm saying something as
it were confident of,
precisely because it's
a little bit inchoate.
If you asked me for a choate thing,
I wouldn't know which choate thing to pick
from the many inchoate things that sorta
covers as possibilities.
I do think that what this view suggests,
I didn't say this but is that
we have...
basically I think we have
lots of pictures of the world,
lots of representations of the world
and they're good for you know,
some of them are good for nothing
and so we should abandon them altogether
but many of them are good for something
and our knowledge is held,
our understanding of the
world in a way is held
in all these partial pictures.
And many of them we don't
know what's wrong with them,
that is they're as Viahinger would say,
hypotheses at the
moment, not yet fictions.
But many of them are fictions
and we're still not going to abandon them.
Because just as...
philosophers of science
found it very hard to say,
you could say the work of Paul Farben
is about this question.
Why do we feel that
there's still some truth
in the Newtonian story after we've learnt
the answer Einsteinian story, right?
Surely the Einsteinian story just shows
the Newtonian story was wrong.
Well, yeah, but that we think
that the Newtonian story
is better than the
medieval impetus theory?
Yes. But what does that mean?
Better in the light of what?
For what purposes?
I think it's hard to say.
And one of the things that I think
reading Viahinger has made
me think about is that
as I said, useful means
useful for some purpose.
I think it's often very unclear
what the purposes are with which we
mobilize our representations.
He says controlling the
world, that is one of them,
but as I said understanding
the world is another
and that's a great deal less clear
what the criteria of
success and failure are
and controlling the world we succeed
if we sort of get what we wanted.
Understanding, it's less
clear to me that we have
sort of this solid picture.
So I would say that my sort of conclusion
from all this is that our
understanding of the world
is held in many incompatible pictures
and that there's a reason
to hold on to some pictures
that are known to be wrong
because the fact that they're wrong,
doesn't mean that they aren't
useful for some purpose.
Though it can be unclear
what that purpose is.
- [Man] Thank you.
- [Campbell] I would really like
to ask you one more question
and I hope I may do that.
I wonder if you really need Dennett
to frame the puzzle that interests you.
And there are two things in Dennett,
One is there's some
kind of instrumentalism.
There's a familiar pattern
where there's a lot of instrumentalism
and then there's a lot of talk about
how I'm not an instrumentalist.
But suppose you were as
uncompromising a realist as you like
about the mental life,
I say consciousness,
rationality, all that's just there,
is got nothing to do reliable
and voluminous prediction.
It's the only bit of the
universe that really matters,
that's what's important
to us the mental life.
Everything else only matters
because of its connection
to the mental life
and that's not to be explained
as instrumental for something else,
that's just there a bit
of reality to be studied.
Now even if you have such a view,
which I take it is opposite to Dennett's
your puzzle it seems to
me you could still raise
because it would still be true,
it would be as true as it ever was
that we are using rationality
as an idealization
in understanding this bit of the world
and your question will still be live.
How does that work?
How can it be helpful to
understand this bit of reality
when we just know that we're not rational.
So the as if comes in twice here.
As if comes in in your picture of what
the psychological life is.
I mean one way of putting
down its pictures to say,
you don't really have a mind,
it's only as if you have a mind
and we can use that to predict.
You don't need that bit.
You want, we've got a
mind, whatever that is
and we use this ideal and
we use this idealization of
as if we were rational
and that's the key thing.
Is that right?
- I think, yes the problem
would still arise on that view.
I'm a little bit interested
in Dennett's way of doing it
because I'm old enough to have grown up
thinking there was an interesting
problem about the minds.
- [Campbell] Oh we do.
(giggling)
- Lots of people nowadays seem to think
that there is--
(both mumble)
And so I'm interested in as it were
the reasons why we might
think that other creatures
including ourselves, have
minds, I mean each other.
I agree that the reasons
why I think I have a mind
might be peculiar and distinctive
but I'm and you know return
is obviously for you.
But I guess I am interested in
whether we can say how it is
that it's possible given the fact
that the way I know what I think
is so different from the way
that you know what you think,
that I can know what you think.
And this whole tradition
which includes Viahinger and Dennett
is sort of broadly empiricists
in its attempt to understand the mind
as not one's own mind,
but the minds of others
including other organisms and humans.
I think in a way...
Look...
there's no practical doubt in my mind
about whether other people have minds,
particular other people have minds.
Some people sometimes have a
kind of moment when they...
I don't have that experience.
But I do have that thought
about some other animals,
as I mentioned sheep.
I'm interested in the question,
how sensible it is to think of them,
it seems to be obvious
that they have perceptions.
That's not one of the
things I'm not clear about.
But I am unclear about how much
one should say about them in terms of
the language of belief, desire,
I don't find myself tempted to
think that they hope things.
I think they have intentions
at least sometimes,
but I'm not sure.
And in trying to decide
what that worry amounts to,
I think the sort of thing
that Dennett is doing
with the intentional sense
is one of the kinds of answers.
But I agree that for you and me,
the question whether...
I don't understand the Churchland view
that it might turn out--
- [Campbell] Yeah.
- It's not that their view
that we could turn out
that we don't have minds,
it's their view that we could turn out
to have minds that were
sort of radically different
from the way they appear to us to be.
I'm really interested in the
sort of thing Charlie works on
which is the relationship
between that story
and the neurobiological story.
It's not that I don't think
that's an interesting question,
but I don't think of the
neurobiological story
as one that could force me
to abandon this other story.
And I'm in part saying that
because of the general view
that I just suggested, which is that
we need lots of stories that
are doing different jobs for us
and I suppose I'm arguing that actually,
against claims for the importance
of the unity of knowledge,
I'm arguing that our
knowledge is held in many,
incompatible systems of representation
and if we were God, maybe
we could integrate them all.
If we were cognitive angels
we could integrate them
although we're not.
And we never will be, so
we're always going to need
lots of different pictures.
And one of the pictures
that I just don't see how
it would make sense for a human
being to try to be without
is this picture of ourselves
as wanting things and hoping
for things and desiring things
and thinking things and having reasons
for doing and thinking and feeling things.
That seems to me,
I just don't know how I could do without.
How we could do without.
- [Campbell] Please come up.
- [Lady] So I'm gonna
go back to two things
that you've said about make-believe
and also about the final image
about going off into the future.
From an empirical perspective,
at least one account you might have
about why kids are making believe,
is that one of the
capacities we need to have
to make cognitive progress,
is the capacity to say here's
the belief that I hold now,
here's how it fits the data,
here's an alternative belief
which I currently do not hold,
which I currently don't think it's true,
I wanna check how that fits the data.
So I have some new set of
data, I've done an experiment
a.k.a. gotten into
everything in my nursery
and now I have a new bunch of data,
I have a current belief,
I check that belief against the data,
but here's an alternative belief
that I'm gonna check against the data.
and if you don't actually
have the cognitive capacity
to say here's an alternative
belief, it's false as of now.
But if it were true, here's
what the consequences would be,
here's the data.
how does that actually fit
with the potential consequences
and the capacity to
sometimes override and say,
"Oh, look at that!
"The thing that I thought before was false
"and this thing is true."
Then you wouldn't be able to make
the kind of cognitive progress
that we actually make.
And from that perspective
what you're doing
when you're making believe is essentially
exercising this capacity to say,
"Here's a premise, it's important
"that I currently think that it's false
"because I don't want to get
confused about my predictions,
"but I can think if it were true,
"that if this were true,
"then here's what the
consequences would be."
So I think there's a relationship between
and I think part of the reason why
it seems plausible to have idealizations
is because we and as a matter
of fact also four-year-olds
know that the current
belief might be susceptible
to this kind of replacement by what,
at the moment is just the as if, beliefs.
So I think there's a
connection between those two
that actually makes sense
out of why it is that
we would be not only entertain as ifs
when we're doing things like make believe,
but the sense in which we could say that
we know that the belief
that we currently have
is gonna turn out to be false,
but it's still useful and
important for us to hold it.
And it's also important for
us to hold the alternative,
to be able to work with
the alternative hypothesis
as if it were true.
- Mhmn.
I don't know what to say,
except that that seems
absolutely right to me,
that seems absolutely right that it is.
Though I would say one
thing which is that,
I think there's a human way of doing this
that is somewhat distinctive because...
Because animals change, other animals
change their beliefs too.
But I don't think my
sheep engaged in kind of
counterfactual reasoning.
So I think that this capacity
for kind of actual reasoning here,
means that we're capable of a
kind of knowledge development
that is very distinctive and
therefore especially important
because it's one of the
reasons why we can do things
cognitively that other organisms,
as far as we know, can't.
- [Lady] And just for what it's worth,
we have historical
co-relationship between kids.
Between how much they're
capable of (mumbles).
- Good.
And as you said they're
conceptually connected, yeah.
Yes, I agree with that, um, thank you.
Yes.
- [Man] Just a brief observation about
usefulness and context.
I think this isn't the spirit of
the way you're thinking about things,
but to say that as if way
of thinking about things
is view useful, that's
something that might make sense
or might be a plausible thing to say
in some context but not others.
And a very natural way
of dividing up context
for some of these purposes
is to is to contrast
the deliberative standpoint with
a retrospective or explanatory
or third personal standpoint.
This is very natural in connection
with this original Kantian idea
that we act under the idea of freedom,
sort of like when you're
moving forward in life,
there's nothing you can really do
with a thought that it's
all determined in advance,
that's not gonna help you decide
what to eat for breakfast, right?
You've gotta make up your
mind and within that context
there's in some way no alternative
but to assume that it's up
to us what we're going to do.
That that same assumption
when we look back
at what people have done in the past maybe
less ultimately, less useful--
- Including ourselves.
- [Man] Including ourselves, exactly.
So I think that's a very...
You were mostly talking about explanatory
and interpretive context or were trying
to predict and explain things but
at least some of these notions
and I think the same
is true of rationality,
notions of reasons,
they have some predictive significance.
And certainly of some significance
in the retrospective point of view
but really, again, it's hard to know
how you're gonna get through life
without assuming that the
fact that a car is coming
bearing down on you is a
reason to get out of the way.
And that that idea has
tremendous significance
in that deliberative context,
which might be entirely independent
from whether it's useful
in other concepts.
Take that to be gristle
for your (mumbles).
- No, no, I think that's very helpful.
And the difficulty I think about
the sort of useful for what question
is that it can sometimes
be hard to articulate
the for what.
We do have some cases,
the practical what am I doing question,
that's one context as
we know how to sort of
define in that rather crude way
but still it's an important way.
As I said I think it's a bit less clear
what it is to say that it's useful
for the purposes of
understanding to say something,
but nevertheless I think I
want to say that sometimes.
And then sometimes...
Just to go back to the make-believe thing,
as I said, adults do make-believe,
that's what we're doing in the theater.
We're responding as if
Juliet just killed herself
because she discovered Romeo
dead on the thing beside her
or is it the other way
around? I can't remember.
And we're moved by that, as we would be
if we came across such an event in reality
but we're not confused
about what's going on.
That means it's all Kendall Walton.
For what, are we doing that?
I don't know.
I mean it's one of the
most important things
that happens to me when
going to the theater,
so it's not that I don't have any doubt
that that for what is
an important for what,
it's just that I don't know that there's
an interesting way of
specifying what it is.
And maybe there doesn't have to be
an interesting one in the sense
of theoretically interesting
maybe it's just one of the
things that human beings
either do or don't get.
So that it's like the funny,
or the amusing.
I don't know that one can
give an interesting account
of the amusing but life
without it would be,
at least for me, less interesting.
Yes, less amusing (laughs).
- [Campbell] We're trying to get one more.
Yes please.
- Hi.
- There's an (clears throat) excuse me.
There's an approach which
seems to me obviously promising
and so I'm wondering if
you have thoughts about it
or problems with it.
When you talk about idealizations
and wonder how can this
fictional thing be useful,
in science and technology,
there's the concept of approximations.
And there're elaborate techniques
for evaluating their
goodness and their utility
for different purposes.
Would that perhaps solve
some of your problems?
- So it's an instance
of, thank you very much.
It's an instance of the general question
and I didn't say much about it in part
because I haven't thought
too much about it,
but also because I think it is as you say,
a relatively well-developed
area of thinking about this.
That is, this is one of the places where
people already have the
idea that it can be useful
to use a picture that's
strictly speaking false,
because it gets you in a certain domain,
approximately the right answer.
I think that's a really
good answer to the question
why you should use a certain
picture in a certain domain.
But of course as was pretty
much explicit in what you said,
being sort of approximately good enough
is relative to a thing
you're trying to understand.
I was once years ago, actually in company
with Richard Braithwaite,
listening to a theoretical physicist
and he was talking about
the fundamental constants.
And he went through a
bunch of mathematics,
very much physicists mathematic,
so lot of gestures here and there.
And at the end he wrote down
122 or something, he said,
"That's close enough to 12!"
(audience laughs) which is
the number he was getting.
Now, (audience laughing)
in a calculation where
you know sometimes
you've been 10 to this 93
and sometimes you've
been 10 to the minus 15,
actually 12 is pretty close 120, right?
But you need to know what the context is,
to decide whether something
is approximately good enough.
I think, again, this is well understood,
I'm not telling you something that you
or other people don't know.
That's a relatively
well-developed area of thought
about one particular kind.
Well known not just by philosophers
but by scientists themselves
'cause they need the notion
of approximation in order to do this work
and they need to be able to decide
when to accept which
approximations for which purposes.
But of course the point is
that you do need to specify
what you're trying to do in
order to decide whether...
Our theory of rational agency,
very often predicts that someone will,
I don't know, buy something.
Then they don't.
Now, but they buy something else.
Is the theory approximately true
because they bought something?
(laughs) Well, that depends on
whether what they bought is sort of
like enough to the thing that you said
they were going to buy I suppose.
Or on whether alternatively,
not treating it as an approximation,
an explanation for why there's a deviation
between what the rational thing was to do
and what they actually did.
They were distracted
by something and so on.
But yeah, approximation, in
the book I'm writing about it.
I'm not gonna talk much
about approximation,
not because I don't think
it's really important,
because it seems to me better understood
than some of these other thing.
But it's a really important
part of the subject.
- [Campbell] That was a delightful
and very stimulating
talk, thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.
(applause)
(upbeat deep bass guitar music)